when you have a financial plan in you
and you have some success in this
position and you're rounding the corner
towards 60 and then 65 and retirement
you have a financial plan you take that
financial plan and you throw it in the
garbage and burn it when you have two
kids in that are this level right yeah I
got I gotta keep working you're gonna be
yes I'm gonna be with Mariska on St you
not like order order in the court haha
you just want to go home is it relaxing
at home
yeah you've got a really involved with
the case your stress and there's AB such
all you really ever know I'm like this
Edwardian right you just shut up I'd
like one of the Windsors you know I'm
sure a lot of a be in like and I bounce
the baby I'm Megan and what kind of a
day did you have today here you are
and I like my pipe and I should bring in
my are you invited canterbury tales'
are you changing the diapers are you are
you involved with feeding the kids and i
my wife is obviously breastfeeding a
newborn baby so she you don't do any of
the breastfeeding I'm right there I'm
right there preserving right but the
being a father and being a husband and
being in those relationships obviously
comes with some stresses and obligations
and sometimes I come home and I'm wiped
out at the end of the day but but but
the the rule typically is and I think
many men feel this way and certainly
women as mothers
they said I'm happier when I'm with them
than when I'm not with them right but
I'm not with my family I'm miserable and
with my wife is like the greatest person
I've ever met in my life
so when you do these shows these things
and they don't work out it's it I joke
with people and I'm not really joking
because I don't want to ruin this but I
have an idea for a show I want to do
there's a job out there in the ether
there's a job out there there's a TV
show that's on right now and I want to
be on that TV show
what is it I'm not going to say what do
you toys anybody's ass if you're
watching what do you say you watching a
show show I would do that you would
never expect I would do and the joke
form of this is what I say to my insert
a comedy or a drama it's a hope I'll be
hosting something price is right I can
see you hosting it there try it out
wheel of fortune come on this is true it
is true let me hear you say Debby
Swanson Peoria come on down
look blood Debbie how are you
what imma do I'm gonna I'm gonna watch -
okay double tap what's the showcase